[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos wünscht ihnen viel vergnügen
moderator im unruhezustand und sieht
viele jahre pensionierte grund zu
sammeln und dann freue mich jetzt
besonders dass sie aus der isolation und
unserem home office ganz legal haus
brachen um der nutzer legal oder vor der
künstlerin wo man schon sieht lang und
total fasziniert nach den einen
90-jährigen marion bach und zwar hier im
kunstmuseum in kürze mein name ist fanny
fischer ich bin direktorin im
kunstmuseum luzern legt aktuelle krise
ist museum geschlossen natürlich umso
mehr freue ich mich dass ich wieder
ganzen zu unternehmen kurt aeschbacher
schön können auch notieren er ist ein
bundespolitik klassische kunst mitmachen
miteinander spazieren
zudem steigt
[Musik]
die soft skills elfter
aber für sie machen wir die geilen
aufhält
[Musik]
retrospektive den ryck betriebs ganzes
lebenswerk vor der marienbader aber mir
fällt mit einer ganz jungen arbeiter wo
sie extra für die eu stelle gemacht
sicher sicher interessanter wie sony da
punkt sie über und die saläre kenne ja
die meisten hütten sie jetzt über die wo
sie überhaupt kennen können sie mit der
jüngsten genau
und dann will ich gar nicht denken dass
es einen ins gehörige traurig ich weiß
nicht wie es ihnen ergangen schicken die
arbeit
ich hab nix für jede aus person und die
helme es so unglaublich elektrifiziert
dass sie gefunden haben
das ist großartig ich habe so etwas noch
nie gesehen und erst nach einer hand
angefangen und die agrokraft und erst
nachher angefangen recherchieren wer die
person ist und sagt merkt dass die
künstlerin wo als lagerraum sich neu
erfunden und mit der unglaublichen
neugier und auch an der wits die kunst
völlig neu erfunden und das denkwerk ist
großartig
[Musik]
neue funde aber sicherlich mehr sich
selber blieben
ich glaube es gibt so thema studieren
und wo nicht die arbeit sehr schmal
ich denke dass ich ganz jungen künstler
und das ist mir bis vormals gott und ich
hatten angemerkt dass gedreht ist ein
tisch dass das nicht über tische aus
stoff mit dem shirley form ist sondern
dass ich auf und nichts material
es ist abfallmaterial und das brauchten
wir ihn nicht im kopf zum akzeptieren
dass wir jetzt in der ausstellung mit
abfallmaterial so besser als kunstobjekt
und teilschritte interessiert mich
daneben eigentlich das macht die viel
interessanter dass sie einen winzig
machte die für mich fantastisch dass ich
merke aber dass eine zeitgenössische
sprache hat obwohl die frau ist nimmt zu
- wenn es gebaut und das jetzt überhaupt
noch stark ist der retrospektiv oder
retro look es zeigt auch dass sie
natürlich eigentlich immer sucht und sie
schaffen mit dem ruhm etwas wahrhaft
also irgendwo
[Musik]
sie spielt der motor der titel außen-
innen- außen- oder das genau umgedreht
um innen außen sind sie sagen ich habe
das aussehen der eigentlich schon eine
wortspielerei residierte womit ein anti
fußstellung vorbereiteten hat sich sehr
stark sagt sie möchte dass die
ausstellung innen außen innen heißt und
ich denke ich habe ich eine aufregendere
kritischere coolere vielleicht sogar ein
englische titel oder sogar und sie hat
im zweiten 1 justiz sie sich einmal ganz
viel sprache innen- außen- innen- und
denn wo mir die umstellung auf parteien
haben ist endlich verstanden dass das
ganz präzise ist wichtig sein
das ist abfallmaterial wo eigentlich
sind da übrig blieben vor dem stoff vor
der textilindustrie und aus der ostsee
vor deiner ärmel und und rock und hose
bei wo man daraus geschnitten oder
ausgestanzt hat macht sie wieder bis wo
ihnen an denen verschlungen ist so dass
mir so etwas in der innen und außen wir
sind in lich leider und aus der kunst ab
dann werden sie dadurch können oder ich
will verstehen und sie durch umgekehrt
es ist hat ganz viel raffiniert sind
eine sehr simple begriff lustigen ist
dass farben schwarz oder brahms und das
hat er damit die sich ja verstehen dass
man sich vorstelle hypertonie in die
bildende kunst tätig ist und über das
wort und musik prima funktioniert
sondern übers lügen verliert augenlicht
und sie hatte in ihrem atelier in ihrer
wohnung ich alles volkswirtschaftler
karten schaftler und notizzettel und
alles so groß geschrieben
mit schwarzer schrift mich ganz wichtig
das zu lesen und so hat sie dann ganz
langsam sich ganzer linie personen
wir haben das 90 das ist absolut toll
die rhume neuen decke
ja das hätte ja mit mit ihrem marx tür
wo textilfabrik am tisch sie und und das
heißt nein die fusion also sie herr
binder fährmann gründeten musikers
verstarb
ja sie hat der firma gründet und sogar
streit im handelsregister
das hat einerseits mit ihrer biografie
weiter mit ihrer aids weiterhin im
textilfabrikant uhr
und dass sie auf diese art von ökonomie
den trend hat sich gerade durch die
musiklandschaft hat aber damit dass sie
in den inspirion mini berühmte
galeristen geschafft hat und der
heckseite ihre werk signieren und das
hat sie nicht wählen dann hat sie ohne
einfach nebenher übernahme und dann
hätte es gar nicht so wenig spektakulär
und dann sind aufnehmen die burschen co
ich stelle mir vor wie einen spray sie
hat ihre kunst eigentlich versprüht mit
diffusen und dann hat sie das label nahm
die funktion aus filmbeiträgen und hat
die firma simuliert und lässt sich das
kunstwerk sie und sie hat ein von der
mitmachausstellung der kaiser ort als
business business als ort grundstück
schafft und schafft ist kunst kunst
übernimmt strategie aus der ökonomie
genannte wirtschaft und umgekehrt und
sie hat mit dem stoff rechtliche da aus
ob man die jetzt könnte ich hoffe das
sind quasi wusste genau was ich mir
vorstellen dass der audi verweist
gemacht das finden die ganz gesunde
spannend dass sie wie kleenex schachteln
oder dass die klinik zu produzieren hat
ja da hat den quasi song give aways mms
oder irgendwo mehr werbung machen
endlich mehr delikte bis mit also ziehen
wir das jetzt passiert wird sie einen
job bei uns in stücke der als mini me
also den ins geraten dann dürfen wir
jetzt die sie gerichtet wo wiener
showroom ist mit der ganzen namen wo
warst aber das ist alles eine illusion
und mythisches wiener reale da die
niedrige firma gleichzeitig ist eine
illusion und gleichzeitig ist politisch
muss st es steht noch da und lief
orchester nummern für wie viel kunst
hätten wir das dass sie schnell
entstanden
das ist anfangs 19 jahren stand er seit
auch in der nachfolger mario barth
verschiedene künstlerinnen und künstler
geht oder die strategie aus der
wirtschaftswelt gruppiert eine firma
gründete sich aus fabrik auskennen mit
als einzelperson aber die ich ganz
zufrieden ich das gemacht hat und sie
macht das ding einfach nur als witz das
ist bis heute das oder schaue kraft
bilden immer aber sie nimmt damit auch
dort mitglied dieser möglichkeit ist die
wirtschaftswelt durchschauen das
funktionieren
unternehmen die fusionierte große
applikation sondern das ist nur
behauptet als ich news ladys marketing
verkaufsstart decken und sie macht
automotive bisher sichtbar ist schön
endlich poesie das ist ironie und das
ist politische kritik
[Musik]
kapitalismus sie da sind
jetzt sogar handy produzieren
fünfmal täglich sehr sehr niedlich aus
kunstmuseum luzern auf deine schöne
sieht erhebliche groninger museum dass
ich das museum in holland und sie hatte
noch stärker und hat für großes videos
sehr schön
sie hat für die ganze aufsicht und für
die ganze team in dem museum die helfer
produzieren oder haben das dann während
der umstellung als uniformen treibt und
mich team ist also wirklich auch linie
die ich würde gern so schön oder sam für
die jungs steckt aber zu sich natürlich
idee dass man nicht wieder wie in reale
wirtschaft sein produzieren
mit dieser idee ist gut ins konzept wir
machen das einmal und jetzt nicht für
jede institution mit dem nein hat sie ja
wahnsinnig spielt ja was dahl
interessant ist eine friedengrund ein
lichtes fertig wenn mir immer lockt
erkennt mir jedes logo die füße nehmen
die forscher
und sie macht eigentlich der kunst aus
dem notfallpaket für kunst ist kunst
werk werden ja genau so richte
transportiert und nämlich aus styropor
das ja alles nur das werk sichere und
dass sie euch großen verpackungsmaterial
als kultur macht das gefällt mir extrem
das finde ich sehr
bis jetzt nicht verstanden dankte klar
das gericht
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das ist für meine lieblings war als ich
aufs valley wo man unendlich fähigkeit
opentv tour
das ist aber nichts beweisen die dazu
bezeichnet weil wir genau weiß nicht ob
es offen ist oder zu die abtei super art
und das ist ja super macht und
supermarktregale und sie macht einen
super art russ und das ist ganz
reduziert objekt sehr ästhetisch aber
sein ganzes jahr wieder ein kommentar
diese heutige wenig aus wie hannes
letzten drei bis vier jahren lebt die
sind ja viel größer und es wird immer
vorlegt juni spricht eine gute gute
arbeit die jetzige krise oder nicht so
wahnsinnig ein beamter
[Musik]
- brasilia sich das wissen in der
situation italien tendenz gehe in dem
design heiter und verspielt wert und das
hat natürlich mit 88 bewege zu dass
menschen nicht einfach noch relativ am
tisch sitze oder der ganze armada von
kanada mit beschlagener bei sondern hat
wählen
der körper befreien und neue formen
ausprobieren und sie hat denn
verschiedene möbelstücke entwickelt wird
zwischen objektkunst möbel teppiche sind
zwischen hockenheim sich auch während
das minuten zog stellten sie das
publikum das dorf benutzt aber das ist
mit seiner alten schule stoff gefüllt
wenn du jetzt du sie verblüht würden
berufsständisches kabul handy das
produziert
jetzt hat mehr produziert sie schon
recht erfolgreich sind dann will es ist
es nicht objekt objekt es ist eben weiß
nicht genau was es ist und das macht das
adjektiv mehr witze grata langen wurde
wie lange der 20 reicht das ist wenn man
darauf hängt willig dass langes
telefonat macht darüber legt mehr
erinnert dass sie mehrere doppel- oder c
wo das bild schließlich machte er froh
wo immer jeder wahl gegangen ist aber
berühmt wurde ist nur der ist
objektleiter oder zu freunden nutzbar
und das ist es doch ließ frauenschicksal
dem medium buch ist sehr handlich
gegangen
das hat aber bis mitte sitzt aber meret
oppenheim hat indycar series objekt
gemacht ein tisch mit vogelbeeren da
kommt mir naja und ist bis heute meine
hand und auch das böse ist ein handel
aber in rechlin ihre version und dann
ist es weniger tun
also ich hoffe schon dass mir jetzt
mitteilung stellt ich so viel erfolg an
dass über gestaltung das wieder
produziert sie daran ag zb ja und dicke
kater danach wie man das dass ich das
ist ja
das zwischending zwischen einer teppich
und objekt und ich glaube es gab bitte
marion war oft umso bis verspielt sehr
ernsthaft die analyse bezieht und welt
und auch sehr kritisch aber den widerruf
presse und nie hoffnungslos weiter
sondern immer für chirurgen und das ist
billig darf sich um ihre meister -
diskutieren können sich einen ski und
die reklame machen retrospektive mehr
logan zurück und sind
[Musik]
juni das erste mal seehafen gedankt
was das ist donald oder war es weg und
stoß amerika und dass sie hat die
gleiche frau gemacht wo die lustige
tiere liefern können sie husten kann
was steckt hinter monitor heißt es
erinnert an der amerikanischen
minimalismus sicher konzeptkünstlerin
interessiert das nicht primär dass das
wissenschaftler sind sondern sie griff
der minimalismus auf wo so stark ist und
dominant in der bildenden kunst und
nennt seine monitore und hat die
glasflächen passt in die holz richter
also wenn es am monitor aber der hält
dir die richterin übersicht
das ist technik buchs das war es mir
wenn wir ein bisschen montiert das segel
worden dass technik buchs liegt wohl
hinterher möbel muss verstecken und dass
die armee die kritikerseite fernsehen
ich wünsche zur welt aber sie führte
dann die ware introspektion als
meditative vorgang also plötzlich ist
der begriff zweitmonitor über das
kunstwerk hinterfragt und das ist ja
eigentlich das was das tolle künstler
dass sie zwinge zum nachdenken
hier hatten sich jetzt extrem schön sein
man muss aber sagen sie hätte denn in
italien bleibt wo in jeder bar bieten
coiffure in jedem zimmer der hai und zu
erklären sofern sie total abgelenkt die
ganze zeit und mit ihrer installation
hat meine volle konzentration und verlor
unglücklich pause
das ist wirklich ein wo liegt
[Musik]
versetzte dass ich dir erste große
umstellung von der einen und jährige
frau wieso ist das so lancom sie ist
natürlich frei in paris lange sie und
hat kleinere projekt macht damit
migranten mit politische gruppierung die
auch gleich dass sie sich wirklich
schaffen machten die rund 1000 milliwatt
legal damit sie ist durch ihre zweite
thema und hat vielleicht nicht wirklich
wissen nur dass das vor allem dem markt
funktioniert und da muss man sagen es
ist erst jetzt möglich dass eine
unbekannte frau welcher umfassend zeigen
das ist woche nicht akzeptierte und mut
braucht für euch als kuratorin und
direktorium vom museum zeigt ja die
zeigen soll
nein für mich hat kein muss braucht für
mich gehört es zum grundauftrag
mittelgroßer museum
wenn ich das eben eine nach linda hoß
wird machen wie es jemand merkte und
wenn ich ein ganz großes haus wird
verantworten
dann könnte ich nicht machen wir dann
müsste ja schon wieder aufwärtsgeht 15
uhr
das geht 100 musik gedreht und ein
mittelgroßes kann eben genau das handy
vergesse ich finde sich interessante
behauptet räumen und untersuchen die
szene mit mir zum publikum quasi
[Musik]
es ist für mich ganz spannung sie hier
hat sie wetter kennt nur wissen über
geschichte und habe die textile war
übrigens das oktober handelt da bin ich
ganz stolz das ist ja leider kommen
grünewald kauft hat mir das elektrisiert
will ich gar nicht verstanden haben ich
hoffe grundsätzlich nur kunst nicht
starr würde mir hilft große sache
plötzlich bestes begriffe dank der
sprach vor der künstler und so mehrere
neue welten aufgekauft hätten mit der
galeristin aus meile was ich vertrete
seit die weiß roten zahlen
dank der also also dass sie hat kein
geld
das ist wirklich so ja das ist also etwa
wedelt wenn sie mal geld hat dann geht
es geradeaus dann zahlt sie als sie
ständen oder gibt verschenkte die
bedürftige sind aber sie hätten mit
ihrem werk wo man die zusammenhänge
kennen lernen miteinander wie groß die
einnahmen generiert das ist immer sehr
bescheiden und ich weiß nicht genau wie
verhältnissen in italien mit dem
rentensystem aber die lebt versehen kann
sie braucht natürlich für sich selber
nie so viel geld aber es ist gott dann
wird es bei 100
hannah war es immer wichtig sie
politische sache sind flüchten aber
rosig um andere menschen kümmern da es
ja in paris i der richtlinie wohnung hat
sie esszimmer kann wo man sich mit
migranten regelmäßig getroffen hat was
steckt hinter der idee
sie hat der linie 210 monika und das
auftischen pariser großes fenster wo
vorne trat das gericht und französischen
balkon und gemerkt nur mittags nicht so
schön
es geht ein schönes ein parkettboden da
hat sich der raum leer grund unter dem
genre wie ein leeres zimmer und hat
linie flyer gemacht und im quartier
verteilt dass man jeden tag einfach an
hu
man sitzt am boden um der lichtfleck wo
andere trinkt tee und man redet
miteinander
und ich glaube das ist sehr typisch für
sie und für mich eigentlich für die
berührendste arbeitet ist ganz einfach
es braucht nicht viel es ist üblich dass
mir alle könnte machen und was man
gleich mitmachen wenn man sich fühlen
wie cd der krise wenn man der veterinär
gehört verzahnt ist das will rauen
sportart ist hektischer zurückzufahren
sondern sagen haben scheinbar wieder als
lars zimmer wo man sich treffen und dann
am zugelassen und geschichte verzeichnet
das wer wird hoffnung dass wir die lücke
unterteilte freie union beansprucht
nicht nur für arbeiter dafür konsum und
ich sage ganz viel glück
was hätte das mit kunst für das doch mit
kunst das ja ganz normales menschliches
vielen mal seit meldet sich gymnastische
grund das könnte auch die punkte ganz
wenig machen so wirklich und das ist
kunst wenn wir nicht nur eine idee hat
oder wenn man sie ausprobiert und
umsetzt und ein andere menschen greifen
und wie sie fahren seit 1
über grund der komplexität für unsere
gegenwart für ihre umwelt verständlich
was hätte die ausstellung pietätlos sie
ist oxid werde nissan micra eine
stattfinde wagenkolonne aber sie hat
immerhin mit ihrer familie und das
andere freunde können durch die rega das
was ich das passiven das erlebnis wenn
wir jetzt einen günstig und das leben
lang geschafft hat und mir möglichkeit
so viel auf einmal in der öffentlichkeit
zeigen
denn haut an das schufa steht also sich
sehr gerührt sie auch sehr prägt ich all
die dame wurde mir gut zu fuß unterwegs
ist und dann sind plötzlich all die
fragen von journalisten und von meinem
publikum wohl gerne möchte ich meine
arbeit von einer preview mit dem art
club luzern oder ständig finanziell
unterstützt und das sind soviel lüth und
fragen sie uns merken dass meine eigene
art menschen berühren und erreichen dass
es funktioniert ich glaube das ist
fantastisch und jetzt freut sich sehr
dass mit umstellung bis mitte oktober
schon verlängern
wir hoffen hat dass sie noch und im juni
zum katalog vernissage
was ist für euch der eigentlich der
punkt was kunst wie der menschen und
chaos lösen aber es sind ganz viele
punkt also was sie fachlich seiten das
virus wurde komplizierte gegenwart
verstört dass man lernt genau worker
dass mir das aber geübt nur eine chance
sieht noch nicht gut dass mir bist du
der welt in der in die welt erlebt dass
man sich auf keinen fall lange will das
ist sicher nicht nur dekorations
unternehmen kompliziert das ist desto
desto besser ich vielleicht oft mit dem
essen als unfried und gecheckt sind
einfach ich schmecke das nicht nur gern
aber bis mit ein irgendwie brokkoli oder
koriander markt
plötzlich aber auch erwachsene
menschheit nicht begangen haben wir ein
bitterer reis oder suri frucht und es
wird gleich interessante geschmäcker
dass man so wie möglich integrieren und
so ist es in die bildende kunst
das erzählte begegnen heißt aber dass
man muss bereits sie sich lassen um
sicher dass man muss bereits neugierige
so stark dass der schlagzeuger und wie
kann er jetzt mit ruth es ist ganz es
gibt für kunsttage medienkünstler kurve
wirklich letzten gehalt besser versteht
sie eine als seismograph auf die
entwicklungen aufmerksam gemacht ohne
vorher gar nicht spürt aber wenn die
lang nur die chance haben wir mit dem
auseinandersetzen
also fliegen und völlig sogar die
bessere mensch ca
[Musik]
[Applaus]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen mehr kultur
swisslos
[Musik]